haven't been in business for nearly 25
years I've hired people that became rock
stars and changed the company and I
recruited people that waste a lot of
time cost money maybe millions of
dollars and eventually I had to learn
how to filter the two out I'm gonna give
you one of the biggest signs on how to
filter these guys out when I tell you
the story it's going to make a lot of
sense to you if you get value out of
this video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel so let me tell
you this story it's eight years ago I'm
sitting down with this one guy let's
call him Anthony okay and he comes in
and he says oh my god Patrick this is
such an honor to meet you I've been
following you in the insurance industry
no wonder everybody talks but you're the
guy to be in business when I'm like okay
I'm always a little careful where it's a
little too much flattery it's a big red
sign red flag for me I'm like okay I'll
receive it hey thank you so much brother
appreciate you man thank you it's great
to meet you as well you might tell me a
little bit about your background you
know how you've done what you've done
well I've been in the insurance space
for 12 years fantastic first five years
I was with New York Life how was New
York Life horrible really yeah tell me
why there's no money to be made the
leaders are this it's a bad company they
don't take care of their people I'm like
okay cool where'd you go afterwards I
went to this other company called
Primerica because they told me they're
going to teach me how to recruit and I'm
going to build an agency and this and
what happened nobody helped me out no
one was doing this all they care about
is this none of them care about that uh
where'd you go after that I went to
Transamerica how was Transamerica nobody
makes money there their products are
this it's all about fees it's all this
is all they care about huh interesting
okay I said can I ask you a question he
says yes I said so 12 years three
companies bad experiences everywhere
absolutely but this is why I've been
looking forward to working with a great
leader like you because I think working
with you it's going to be awesome I've
never worked with somebody great I've
never done this I'm so excited about
this it's going to be life-changing I
said um
can I be direct with you yeah of course
uh how how long do you think it'll take
before I'm the fourth company you're
going to hate
what do you mean well I mean New York
Life I know a lot of great people there
companies been around for a long time
they've changed a lot of people's lives
people make millions of dollars they got
good products they got a great brand
same with Primerica I can say and trans
great leaders change a lot of people's
lives money all of that I don't solve
for Perfection I suffer results all
three of them get great results with
people that want to do things so if
you're talking bad about those other
three companies I'm gonna be the fourth
one soon don't you think I would never
do that to you see the difference is you
I'm not trying to say all these guys are
bad on all this other stuff but it's you
so red flag flattery second if a person
tells me bad things about the last three
people they've worked with you're going
to be the fourth if a girl you go on a
date with she talks badly about all her
exes you're gonna be the next one if a
guy you're hiring tells you how horrible
their bosses have been at the last 20
companies you're going to be the 21st
this is not the company it's the
individual and you'll be next do not
fall for flattery and have a big red
flag when somebody's talking badly about
all the different companies and amateur
is going to fall forward because you
want flattery in the compliments oh my
God I'm so amazing yes you're right I am
different you're not different
that person is going to come here bring
you a lot of headaches steal hundreds of
hours of your time deceive you use
flattery use guilt eventually when
something doesn't go their way you see
what happened nobody did this nobody did
that and that is why I failed and then
they're gonna go to the fifth company
and tell the story you know what
happened with that story that person
came on board okay because I was in the
decision maker of this person coming on
board somebody else was able to choose
this person to work with them I said
look I'm not working with them you can
pick and choose the guy comes on board
you know what happens two years later we
became the fourth company okay this was
like four or five years ago we became
the Ford Company why because that's a
trend okay it's going to constantly
happen with people that are always
complaining about the situation so
instead what I would rather hear in an
interview somebody to say you know what
I was with XYZ company for this many
years great experience learned a lot
from John Doe papa papa when I decided
to leave at that point because the
person I was working with retired so I
kind of my loyalty I really enjoyed
working with them I decided to go to XYZ
place because my wife was best friends
with this lady who her husband will have
been I went over there worked great made
a lot of changes and then that person
moved to a different place I eventually
went and worked over here and now quite
frankly I'd love to work with you
because I see the opportunity here with
the company you guys are growing I'd
love to get a shout out working with you
guys it's a very different language than
blame blame blame it's a clear clear
sign that you'll see to be careful for
when certain people that are complaining
about their bosses friends access
everybody typically you're going to be
the next one having said that if you got
value from the video give it a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel there's another
video I want you to watch is how to
choose your business partner if you've
never seen this before click here to
watch that video take care everybody bye
[Music]